[Musique]
ça c'est new york new york il ya quatre
ans un taureau rouge des prés qui fait
1450 kg et c'est la bête qu'on aurait dû
emmener cette année au salon de
l'agriculture
le salon de l'agriculture c'est presque
le domaine d'antoine jaffray le voici à
la porte de versailles à l'âge de 15 ans
avec le taureau fêtards deuxième prix du
jury cette année là venir ici est
deuxième c'est énorme et d'avoir mon
fils et mon père qui est avec moi c'est
génial
l'année suivante fêtards et même sacré
champion du monde des taureaux de la
race rouge des prés ce titre s'affiche
toujours sur les murs de la ferme
parmi les dizaines de récompenses
d'accumuler aujourd'hui à seulement 21
ans antoine s'est vu confier les rênes
de l'élevage familial
la crise sanitaire aurait pu rendre la
passation compliqué mais l'année 2020 a
plutôt été un révélateur
elle l'a conforté dans ses choix de
vente directe des produits de la ferme
normalement on a une moyenne de départ
de vache pour l'abattoir on va dire de 2
voire deux et demi par mois et par
exemple au premier confinement en mars
avril on a passé douze vaches en deux
mois quoi on va dire que sur les bêtes
qu'on a fait partir au mois de mars ce
ne sont pas des clients réguliers
puisque c'étaient des propriétaires de
qui sont descendus de la capitale pour
venir se confiner en sologne mais
derrière on a réussi à sortir des
débouchés vial et les maisons de
retraite
les collèges les lycées donc toutes les
collectivités du secteur
et tout compte fait ça c'est un marché
qui ne se perd pas désormais le père
d'antoine se consacre aux livraisons et
le jeune homme et vit tout intermédiaire
notamment dans ce poulailler
il ya 50 ça ce bâtiment
quand je travaille des intégrateurs on
était rendu à six ou sept mille poules
est donc des intégrateurs qui arrivait à
se faire sur une année donc on fait à
peu près six bandes par année qui se
faisait à peu près cent mille euros sur
notre dos juste en faisant les commandes
et les départs quand nous il nous reste
et 1000 euros pour payer toutes nos
charges donc c'est à dire bénéfice net 0
aujourd'hui nous on a des poulets comme
cela qu'ils vont partir et en faire deux
kilos 5,3 kg de viande
je vais les vendre 12 euros le poulet
même pas au kilo c'est le couler
aujourd'hui vous allez allez dans un
supermarché un poulet de 1 kg 5 qui va
être vendu 10 ou 12 euros le kilo pour
tout le monde c'est bénéfique pour nous
comme pour le consommateur et le
consommateur c'est comment son poulet a
été élevé
la pandémie a donc créé un choc
salutaire et redonner de la fierté aux
éleveurs qui ont opté pour la vente
directe
ils ont enfin la maîtrise de leur avenir